welcome to this video a new part on
opening disasters yeah this is featuring
a game between darshan Kumar and red
master Kumaran and grandmaster tony
miles anthony miles this game is from
1993 and if you are very young then you
probably don't know both players at
least there that's possible
yeah Kamala was a very we start with the
white player was a very promising
British junior player at the time this
game was played 1993 was 18 years old
and back then was international master
yet he got the Grandmaster title
somewhat later but retired from process
in his early 20s so quite a long time
ago um I think 2000 2001 is his last
recorded game if I look this up
correctly he is now working as a in
medicine doing something with with brain
science but he's not playing chess
anymore unfortunately it's always hard
to understand for me that people would
retire completely from playing chess and
not at least play the occasional league
game or tournament just to enjoy the
game but okay it's not playing anymore
and yeah Tony might has probably even
known to the younger players he was the
first young modern British Grandmaster
at least that if he was the first
Grandmaster after this title was
officially introduced in the 50s and he
was one of the world's top players in
the late 70s early 80s well-known for
his original and funny ideas sometimes
he played famously he played this is
black against and then watch champion
Karpov and one pretty much yeah after I
mean this is very well known that he won
this game but it's less unknown that he
lost almost all other games that he
played against cobble
and in this game he also was lost but
Cup of blundered later yeah he was a
very interesting person and very
inventive player unfortunately he died
really at a young age at 40 46 years old
in 2001 okay let's look at the game by
the way I had the privilege of playing
miles once in 1997 and open in the
Netherlands I I lost the game there was
quite nice
I lost the score sheet unfortunately so
I cannot really show the game and it's
not in the databases so I am it's one of
those casualties where I lost them of
the game in some harddrive issue years
ago okay let's look at the game at home
to be happen already a funny start ste
496 this is a typical miles he tried to
be be creative early 93 good reply d5 g3
of course white can play C form for the
chicken but many players prefer to delay
this move me included I play Bishop f4
in this position not really going for a
London system in a way I would just want
to play III and c4 later and want to do
this with the bishop out it's a little
bit more conservative than going c4 but
not a huge not a huge deal Kumaran plays
g3 which also is fine just develop the
king side and now miles goes for the
most aggressive approach Bishop g4
Bishop f5 is also possible Bishop g2
Queen d7 AHA c4 e6 castles and long
castles so this is really what this game
is about black really quickly got in
long castling
and yeah long castle's is not so so
common in chess if you want to look at
it from a statistical point if you very
often or much more often you see short
cancelling yeah long castle's comes with
with some problems and many times and
the inherent issue with long cancelling
is that very often it takes two weeks
it's a funny funny expression that I
originally heard from German Grandmaster
Klaus Bischoff he said in one of us when
he was doing a commentary on a
grandmaster game he said that yeah along
castles it's called long castles because
it takes two moves you also always have
to play the King again here in this case
to put it on b8 to really complete the
castling so there is a there is a grain
of there's some some true than that and
we see in this game um how this somewhat
funny expression can play out in a game
yeah come on up late night c3 and Myles
took on C form yeah Knight c3 is of
course designed to put more pressure on
the center and maybe at some point also
play 95 releasing this Bishop to make
more pressure on the centre black could
have thought about a developing move but
if we look at night f6 now we see that
95 is already very awkward you know in
this situation we threaten here with red
in the Queen Black has to take the
Sweeney know why the move and after this
we see that this is a very unlucky piece
that does not have any great place to go
and relatively best is this but now you
just lose this Palmer deform without
anything to show for it
yeah black just not really it's not
really able to play that he went with
the capture which seems to be okay but
entails some risk as we will see kumara
now goes with Queen a4
and here we come to the critical
position of this game very very early
yeah it's a not cold called opening
disaster without reason
yeah here we come to to a situation
where exactly this saying of Klaus
bishop is a bishop is applying long
castling very often takes two moves here
the Queen on a form should really yeah
start to to ring alarm bells in Black's
head
the queen is pressurizing c6 here the
cool annoyed and especially a7 this pawn
is only protected by the night long
castles is in a way always in tailing
this weakness of this a pawn
yeah Queen a far if a for Queen a5 those
kind of moves can always put pressure on
the pawn and here black absolutely
absolutely needed to play king b8 that's
really the only way to play him a black
could consider to take here it is risky
but maybe playable if we start with this
yeah it looks it looks crazy at first
but maybe Queen a7 Jetix here and Queen
c6 while looking crazy it might still be
playable more solid and really advisable
here is the move King v8 which is the
second movement of the complete long
castling now you have a seven protected
yeah why is this this big of a problem
a7 we will see very very clearly in the
game continuation miles now play the
move Bishop to b4 and after that move he
is lost
it's just like that black now is lost
with good play by white and Kumar and
plays this game absolutely flawlessly he
now plays and this is really not such a
surprising move
and makes the whole thing a bit
mysterious what exactly miles has
overlooked when he played the ship
before he now went 95 yeah and this is
just unleashing this Bishop very clearly
and it attacks the knight on c6 by also
attacking the bishop on g4
so black must take no other move and now
the big problem is apparent why does no
of course not taking only 5 or before
but he is taking on a 7 and this is just
devastating
b7 mate the queen bees have mate is the
threat and black really has barely has a
reply to prevent the mate if he goes to
c6 check check mate have this nice
little mate and yeah what else is there
really if you move the Queen somewhere
to give some room for the king and let's
say here white um yeah has some good
moves but easiest is to just take here
and then next grab on b7
yeah c6 Knight a4 is also ending in a
complete destruction yeah he went to c6
probably the relatively best choice yeah
now white can just take on e5 with a
good position definitely with probably
also win but there is an even more
powerful move and this was played by
Kumar on Bishop to M for developing this
piece and getting the bishop here on a
great attacking diagonal black now
cannot move the knight quite obviously
as this is Surf Shack late direct made
so cannot move the knight and yeah what
should he do Queen takes d4 and there's
clan 8 king c7 Bishop e5 it's not
convincing can still falter but Knight
b5 is the big problem
yeah funny move takes Jack take cm and
rook 81 winning in the house 95 King b6
check checkmate
it's a nice little maid yeah in the game
miles played Bishop to d6 and really
there was no big alternative Jack we
need now king c7 if black I was Bishop
the 8th we just take here and next week
lab mmm b8 with the piece and a mating
attack so everything had once okay this
is the move that was played in the game
and now from here White has a forced
checkmate
she want to treat it as a little puzzle
you can try to find the major it's a
maiden I think four moves okay I'm going
to show you now it's a bit comparable to
a line that we had earlier the decisive
movie is giant b5 check if black takes
it checkmate we have this made and if
you place king b6 this was played in the
game white is playing exactly an a7
check King b5 only move China for check
here miles resigned 1-1 move before made
King before maybe six estimate black
king is mated on before does not happen
that often early early in the game
yeah so a great great opening disaster
here for black which is due to the due
to the move Bishop to b4 which neglected
this typical issue the pawn on oops the
pawn on a 7
let me look once again here
it's very typical that this Knight is
dislodged from c6 and then with clean
air 7 we get this attack going if we
once more look at this position we
should still find out how this is to be
evaluated if black played correctly
after King b8 it's not totally clear how
wide should play um
the interesting moves are Bishop e3 or
rook t1 if we look at rook to e1 may be
a possible variation here could be the
capture and takes and now we have an
interesting moment Knight takes d4 which
looks good at first is losing
immediately due to rook Jake's yeah now
black cannot trade here as this is made
direct made he has to take here to make
some sense and then Bishop e3 is the
decisive move again using the a7
weakness yeah here black is getting
completely club at yonder on the King so
you cannot take on d4 at all but what
black can do he can play night before
which leads to an interesting position
now it is difficult for y to avoid the
Queen trade if not impossible so
probably Queen trading group takes and
it continues from here White has the
bishop pair and a good central control
but black has the pawn the pawn on c4
yeah a possible way to continue could be
rook b1 intending b3 to open up the B
file an interesting position so black
really had a playable position up to the
point where he played Bishop before
maybe Bishop e3 also comes into
consideration if now this Queen C for me
is leading to an interesting position
where Jack White has a very good
development as compensation for his pawn
yes some attack attacking chances say
based on 95
like that so it was the whole opening
concept that might let my displayed what
some somewhat risky but not necessarily
bad it however placed the burden on him
to be very very accurate and with Bishop
before he somehow failed to recognize
that 95 was that devastating yeah and a
good reminder to to be cautious with
long castling it's not like you have to
be afraid all the time when you do it
but always keep in mind that there is
some inherent weakness on the on the
queenside like here this is a seven or a
two for why it's so very often the move
like king b1 or king b8 does make
sometimes this make very concrete sense
or very often is just a good
prophylactic move to to follow the long
castles just to make your King a little
bit more safer okay I hope you enjoyed
this thanks for watching